Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson now seems to be sucking
up to failed former President Donald Trump
after the text messages were revealed, in which
Tucker admits to hating Trump passionately. This
is very interesting, and I want you to remember
that the number one priority there's really two
priorities for almost all in corporate media
priority. Number one is ratings. And priority
number two is maintaining access to the most
powerful people you can possibly maintain
access to. Despite the reality that Tucker
Carlson hates Trump, quote, passionately,
he doesn't want to be on the outs if Trump
is again president of the United States. And
so the day after his text messages attacking
Trump were leaked, Tucker Carlson goes on TV
and talks about all of the great ideas that
Donald Trump is now proposing. Take a listen
to this. You wouldn't know it from.
Speaker 3: Watching the news media,
but Donald Trump is running for president again.
Speaker 1: Right? So, first of all, the media
isn't giving Trump enough attention.
Speaker 3: Put him in prison first,
which of course, their plan and
he's saying things that are really.
Speaker 1: Interesting. Trump is
saying interesting things, but you
hate him passionately and you think he's an idiot.
Speaker 3: Rehashes at all the fact he's come out
with a bunch of proposals that were so interesting
that we thought we would bring them to you. We've
asked Fox's Kevin Corke to bring us the story.
Speaker 1: Okay. So then he brings on Kevin
Corke. And if you thought that Tucker was
being sarcastic because, look, I just told
you what the proposals are, it includes flying
cars. If you thought that Tucker was kidding,
he's not. This is a serious segment.
Speaker 2: A good idea often begins with a.
Speaker 1: Very single thought.
Speaker 3: Tucker. Kevin Corke, thanks so much.
More babies, prettier buildings, cleaner
parks. Those are achievable goals once we
improve everyone's life.
Speaker 1: He's taking
it seriously. Tucker is pretending like these
are reasonable and good ideas. So this is this
is very overt. Tucker Now having to suck up to
Donald Trump. And I don't know what happened
behind the scenes when Tucker's text messages
leaked saying he hates Trump passionately. It's
completely plausible that Tucker and his producer
and FOX brass got together and said, listen,
I get it. You hate him. I get it. Listen, we
all hate him. Maybe it was even said behind
the scenes, but he could be the president.
And we want to host a primary debate and we
want to host a presidential debate. And we
can't have Trump furious with us. And he's
increasingly furious with us. So you got to go
and clean this up. That's a completely plausible
conversation that could have happened behind
the scenes. These ideas, nicer buildings and
flying cars and all this different stuff. If it
were a Democrat that was proposing this stuff,
Tucker Carlson would be doing his psychopathic
laugh and talking about how unreasonable and
expensive and unfair to the American
taxpayer it would be to pursue these
ideas. So don't fall for it. Tucker is trying
to clean up his mess. It might actually work